yeah oh is that you up there last camera
what am i doing I'm swimming on the raft
they look like a pervert
hey here we go hey get out of my mirror
that's some pretty nice yeah there oh
they're so smoothly shade Oh God hello
ass let me touch it
I'm close area but ah where did you go
Dec coming up whoa what are you doing
stop it
Hey hey Dad hey doing do have my hands
folded like you do yeah hey oh you've
red hair if you're born yeah so can I
touch your skull please oh let me touch
your skull
let me touch it mmm let me let me lick
your nips come on don't do that
underwire did it it it it did it did it
did it it it did under dicey under the
sea I'm sorry to the people watching
this because my face is buried in my
chest right now
whoa what is that oh my god this is
amazing
I see a giant zit I want to pop it yeah
I don't pop that is your guesting you
how do I cut it this looks like a giant
brain I'll take a picture of this giant
brain it had needs to be documented
great selfie selfie tickle it make a
pose even though that's not a selfie
it's a whatever it is make a pose must
be able to do hand gestures in this game
yeah man yeah man wha oh oh oh yeah this
is really weird I'm swimming inside your
jug this is what underwater actually
looks like yes it is deck this is we
know you don't have underwater in
Ireland we're an island god dammit can I
go visit you in your house ha ha you'll
swim up to this short of Brighton just
yeah it's just right up on the beach and
then a kid you keep walking up the beach
and then a little bit more and then you
you knock on my door and then you to
come you heard of here folks
that's how you find his house oh god no
edit that out
I'm not swimming on the side this is how
we do it from pum pum pum pum pum pum
pum pum rum
landshark landshark what is this this is
amazing
oh how low is gonna give out tall oh oh
what's going on over the sea over the
sea yeah
oh okay so broken skate say you're still
making bubbles come out of you as well
of course Oh somebody's here
there's Cal oh my god Cal yeah huh don't
come here now uh-huh
wait wait is the beach party where's our
two hot the beaches all that
beachy ha ha ha yeah where's the hot
beaches I love me some hot beaches I'm
gonna take a picture of these I'm taking
great pictures oh I got a penny shot oh
ha ha ha
see like she has a one-piece ah but
followed the other girl she has like
legs what an ass cheek yeah but you have
links to Jesus cheeks
well everyone has asked cheeks Jack it's
not a big thing what hallo see hallo
when you wait I gotta funds what well
you get a flashlight that usually means
something's coming to kill you which I
need to be able to see I think the
ambience changed as well there's a boat
here you need to come here Jack you're
gonna get killed by shark
there's fishes look where's Josh look
this vicious and they're suspicious
vicious but Jack you need to come over
here right now the boat is coming into
view yes I feel like James Cameron right
now I am James Cameron's soul oh there
is a flashlight down there why would I
lie to you jack - you're horrible person
you're right but why else would I lie to
you it better not be a shark hiding
anyway - here
Oh who's this gentleman oh it's you all
right okay I kind of have like an
octopus phobia so there better not be
any octopus ease yeah why are there
stained glass windows on a boat tire of
this is not a church follow the worst
thing you could put on a boat hey pers
look it's your best friend barrel yo
look at Dan what are you doing me
Oh God they follow us let me poke you
I'm a poker Oh poker face but poor poker
face is it bad that I'm like aiming
right at her
what why I relate a poker but okay Jen
Jen Jen Jen Jen Jen Jen turned and drag
and doesn't touch me okay wait oh my god
your tank is coming through your junk
and it looks oh yeah oh oh what the
hostess clothes decision cow
god damn you kid oh my god pool party
let's all get drunk and naked I want to
get out of the pool and get some drinks
stay there Jack I got this yeah bring me
a mai tai
can we go inside this tank or whatever
or like yeah this is like the fault whoa
this is like a safe little bubble so we
can't week if we're shark attacks us
your baldness will just blind them and
they'll go away we're the fish in the
aquarium oh that's deep man
daddy so it's almost as deep as the
ocean oh my god jizz ah oh that's like a
Bigfoot hole that we just went through
ah I like it
sharks oh they're dolphins they're
dolphins laser tag there's dolphins Oh
they fart oh god is disgusting I'm over
here how do I stab them Oh Walter shut
oh here we go
let's do this uh okay all right go go go
daddy daddy I take a picture
Oh ah didn't count know what I'm doing
wrong this is worse than Pokemon snap
really yeah got one Oh swimming away top
I just wanted to make it pictures you
got I just want to make sweet lovemaking
don't say that it's vicious that's
abusive behavior it's vicious with the
vicious vicious vicious Oh this
fish is stuck
it's my batch I failed what the
I'll look her hair is like a spoon super
freaky oh my god her hair is an octopus
here
the way I got it smashing your mic I got
it the point I mean while I'm doing your
hair